hey what's up
I'm Geo I'm Bart and welcome to get
close and I wanted to ask you me yes
what was something or anything that you
did that you never thought you could
um
lead people
really yeah
I never thought I could lead people not
that I I never wanted to
um and then I think when I was put in a
position where I needed to lead I didn't
know how to how come you never wanted to
because that requires being the center
of attention and I want to be the center
of attention really so like growing up
like let's say class projects or like in
a sports team or any extracurricular
activities
um you never go oh I want to do it I
want to be the leader never the leader
really yeah I never want to be the
leader and sometimes it it happens that
way because I'm already quickly going
like okay cool cool okay what else we
got to do and I'm already kind of like
talking that way that people are like
now what and I'm like what the you
looking at me for because I feel like
you're like oh yeah kids um actually
like you because they want to do what
they want right so they're like I want
to be the leader okay we're gonna play
arcades and I was like no I want to go
do this first
mm-hmm so someone said I want to do our
kids go okay let's go play our kids yeah
oh wow yeah I didn't like it I just oh
like as a kid I probably
but I didn't see it as a leader I just
wanted to do what I wanted to do but the
older I got I'm like don't pay attention
to me leave me alone
Lee don't look in my direction because
doing what you want to do is like the
first start of being a leader
you're the one with the vision you just
need more people to execute it but
you're also trying to figure out if
everyone else has the same vision too
yeah maybe I had low self-esteem too
where I'm like
don't listen to my vision it's whatever
like it's stupid like whatever damn
well I mean yeah I just don't want any
type of attention and I don't want
people giving me their two cents when I
don't even respect it you know what I
mean like if I think something's rad and
I don't think you're bad and now you're
talking about my rad I'm like who
the are you like you're not even
rad you know so I'm like don't even
meddle on my so people that aren't
rad they tell you stuff it just bounces
off you yeah because they're not red oh
yeah but if someone rad we're just like
oh teach me but but the amount of times
that I ran into people that are super
bad is super rare
so I mean yeah I just don't want to be
the center of attention ever
that's true and then how did you uh and
now you feel comfortable leading and
you're like I could do this all day yeah
pretty much how long how did it take you
to do that
up until now how did it take you like oh
how yeah what was the process like how
did you progress into this so
I didn't work many jobs okay so like
um
I guess the first time you could say I
started actually working I wasn't
getting paid for it but my mom worked at
a school so like after school she would
still stay doing work like stapling
xeroxing organizing a bunch of for
her students or whatever
um so I would help with that right so if
she needed a Xerox some I would do
it so like early on I already understood
like tasks and jobs and all that
and responsibilities so I would do all
of that then my first official job
wasn't until I was 18.
so I didn't really get a lot of
experience with like high level
management
um and that first job it was working at
a bookstore like a mom-and-pop bookstore
so it wasn't even like the school
bookstore it was like a mom-and-pop
bookstore
um literally I was the only employee
maybe maybe it was like two or three
there was like an opener and a closer
and maybe like someone a floater or some
um and then after that I worked at the
bank so not super corporate
um and it had like assistant manager
manager but it wasn't anything that like
that one is the absolute opposite of the
small business right because it's super
Fortune 500 big corporate
um
so I didn't really get to see like
organic management it was it felt like
everything was super scripted like they
needed to follow this protocol
um they needed to use these key phrases
because you're selling like it just felt
so again scripted and vague
um and then I have to and then I come
into JK and that's my
third official job if you will
um and now it's like it's like weird
leading the charge right because
whatever we were doing back in the day
didn't exist you didn't have any
experience with owning your own company
I didn't either or like starting a
company so I didn't know anything so at
that point that's when I learned that
like we all wear different hats and like
you need marketing and finance and
um producing or like you just need all
these different roles and at that point
we were all like wearing seven different
hats
um and then it got to the point where we
grew a little bit and then I was
um I was uh uh training people so that's
kind of my first stint or my first state
uh taste and producing yes in producing
specifically
um but I didn't see it as like leading
right but to a certain extent you kind
of are like kind of like passing on the
skill set yes but in a certain extent
you kind of are leading because they're
answering to you right
um I didn't feel I was really good at
that I mean I don't really know I didn't
really get feedback on that
um so I'm like all right whatever now we
start our own thing and it's literally
you and I like we we literally have to
lead yeah everyone looks to us for
answers yeah because we're creating it
so we are the answer key yeah
so then at this point I'm leading on you
heavily because one I don't like to lead
I don't want to be the leader two you
already have your experience because
you've had JK you've been leading I'm
not the leader in that thing so I I was
leaning on you heavy for that
um so
like I just felt like I'm just kind of
supporting
this other half of the vision that was
barbell oh I see yeah
um and then the more we started
splitting up the roles because the
company started growing the more I was
forced to kind of just move into areas
that you know we noticed we were just
naturally stronger at right so you're
naturally stronger creatively
um you're naturally stronger
um
um liftingly yeah sure liftingly and I'm
just I'm just naturally
stronger at like people management uh
like HR like operations
um and all of that stuff so it just
didn't make sense at that point in
business and I'm talking about now this
is like
maybe even a 10 year stint of like all
these different ups and downs and roller
coasters and different like type of like
job placements and just different hats
that I've been wearing different
situations wins losses failure success
stories you know that I've been just
Gathering a bunch of data and we're now
to the point where
um barbell is doing pretty good we start
splitting up our roles just to be more
effective and efficient we have a really
solid team now
um I have like this new phone like
self-confidence with my own ability and
my skills and I'm like learning a lot
and working on myself a lot
that like I just started noticing how
well I can connect with people and
motivate people and like
um really see what people's strengths
are and like place them in really cool
like place them in situations where
they're going to thrive or in positions
I should say where they're gonna Thrive
um and that just felt good like it just
felt natural
um and I didn't even realize that I was
really leading but I was right because
they're coming to me for answers they're
coming to me for vision they're coming
to me for everything
um but it was it like those are like the
the highlights of it but then the The
Not So highlights are like you know when
like I have to let someone go or I have
to hire people like that's these are not
not necessarily the hiring but like the
Letting Go people is he's rough you know
because it's like no one wants to be
like oh yeah it's so confrontational it
is it's very confrontational I don't
really necessarily have problems with
confrontation I'm okay with that and by
confrontation I don't mean like fighting
confrontation it's just
face to face yeah having a hard
conversation with people that's right
and you gotta like about to let them
know the next chapter of the life is not
good
um yeah or just that we're moving in
different directions like it's not good
fine
um not necessarily it could be yeah
um and then so like in leading a team
like you have to know what you're
talking about you have to instill
confidence in them that you're gonna
take care of them that uh you're
steering the ship in the right direction
you know that you're like seeing their
strengths highlighting their strengths
um looking at their coaching
opportunities and coaching them with
that because it's not fair to like
be all disgruntled as a leader and not
like give your team feedback because
your team's there because they want to
see the team win you know yeah
um
so like it was a lot of
unfucking and like mine in Paradise the
Paradigm shifting that I needed to do it
was there a moment when you're doing all
of this that you're like holy I
didn't think I could do any of this
before and you like impressed yourself
this year uh last year last year was
that for me because
um
I had taken it two two years off right
when I had taika when I came back I just
felt like the business wasn't in a place
that was satisfactory to me and I felt
like my team
um wasn't thriving as much as I knew
that they could and then at that point I
was like you're busy doing your
position you know the rest of the guys
are busy Manning their position if I see
this
um I I mean we just there's an empty
space here like I need to fill it you
know it didn't matter if I was if I was
gonna like it or not like I knew I
didn't want to do it but I knew it had
to get done right so then kind of
looking at what we needed in terms of
business and then going all right well I
guess I just have to be the person that
does it when I started getting it done
that I was just like oh holy I did
all that by myself
like I cut costs I brought in key
players got rid of not key players
um I I changed a bunch of like the
business models for us like I I I was I
was able to help you succeed in your
area my other teammates helped succeed
in that area and like I had done it all
by myself like I told you guys this is
my plan this is what I'm gonna do and
then like I'm actually getting it done
and I'm like holy I
did I just do that like it was really
surprising did you feel like really
proud of yourself when that happened
absolutely it was a huge achievement
because
remember I was leaning on you in the
beginning because I'm like you're the
expert in this I'm just learning as we
go you know and I think a part of me was
also using that as a crutch because I
was scared yeah you know because it it
it forces me to get out of my comfort
zone and if we get caught up in the
comfort zone we don't want to leave it
you know but
um
yeah I think subconsciously I was just
telling myself like oh he knows what
he's doing like I just I gotta trust
Bart like we're just gonna do that you
know yeah but I would see things and I'm
like that's not how I would do it that's
not how I would do that that's how I
would do that you know and it wouldn't
be fair of me as an equal owner to just
be like bar what's going on you know it
should be like okay you know what I see
that there are these areas are you cool
if I go and like this is what my plan is
you know and we talk about it and
obviously you agree to all these things
too and if there were things that you
didn't agree with that I was thinking
about doing then of course we have a
conversation and that's really rad that
we can even have
um a partnership like that
um but yeah looking back at it I'm like
this is tight you know like I it
was very uncomfortable it was very
uncomfortable and in the beginning I
felt like I was over explaining myself
and then
um
um I just had to turn a lot of these
insecure voices off in my head and just
be like what is the goal what
are you trying to do how do we get there
um and just kind of repeat their mom
what this whole like Renaissance
no what how why would I yeah why would I
share it well I feel like
um you know our parents are there kind
of like to witness the majority of our
maturation
and so it's almost as if they see you as
an organism right and then when you
yourself become a different organism
I feel like it's such a cool thing to
share and then to like share with your
mom like hey you you know like this
whole time like we both thought we were
I was a caterpillar but I'm a butterfly
excuse me
um
and to share that win
with her because she might be like
really proud you know yeah I think she's
really proud already
um and it's been one of those things
that
um I don't know the internal like
Metamorphosis that needed to happen to
become what you see on the outside you
know yeah I also never put it together
like this right because I don't ask
myself like Geo what are you what is
something that you didn't think you were
gonna do that you are accomplishing that
you accomplished really yeah it's not
something that I've ever like
put together in my brain to be like
that's sick I'm proud of that
you know like
um I am proud of those moments but I see
them as the moments just as that
singular yeah I didn't see it as like
this like this essay you're gonna put
together to share with your mom yeah
yeah yeah yeah so like guys like
situations would arise like if like I
don't know we're going through like some
like legal issue or some you know
normally I'm like uh can the big dogs
take care of this right but it's like
well who's the big dogs it's you
you dumb you know and then I'm
like oh that's uh that's me I'm the
boss here you know and I have to like
talk with the lawyer and go back and
forth and document and now I'm like
talking to our Finance person
I'm talking to like it's just so as like
these little things would pop up and I'm
stressed about it or whatever like I
would talk to her about it and then I
would talk to her about like how I
concluded it or how it was resolved what
did she say she go wow you guys go
through a lot
um or deal with a lot I'm sure I'm sure
something along those lines but it's
more so what she's like I know she's
proud or she's like man you're a badass
you know
um but yeah I've never really put it
together like that I think you should I
don't even know how like how would I I
don't even know why I would want to
bring that up just to share that I don't
know I feel like outside of me the next
closest person is your mom and it's
always cool to like
um like update your mom on who you are
as a person
maybe if it comes if it comes up
organically I don't think it's gonna be
one of those like let's sit down and
have a conversation about me
oh interesting no I don't think so I
can't wait to update my mom about
things that have happened
I update her about things that have
happened but the way it's packaged right
now where I'm like I'm really proud of
that or whatever like I don't think that
way so it's not something that I'm
presenting to her like wrapped like that
you know but like as I'm going through
my Feats and my failures with her
um as I'm going through it I'm updating
her as I go like oh this week or like
did I tell you this happened or this and
then like this is how this is where
we're at with it now like she's in the
know with all of that stuff I see yeah
so that's pretty cool in that
um I know she's really proud of me you
know and I know she sees that I have
become a butterfly
long time ago
yeah but this like if you were to ask
Geo of like
2008 that she turned into what I am now
she'd be like no way yeah it's
pretty cool I was the complete opposite
I always wanted to be the leader okay
like um
even starting with Kung Fu
like the minute I was like oh I
think there's a potential for me to be
like the youngest black belt in class I
wanted to do that and then like the way
that you do forms is the highest ranking
person gets to be the the front kind of
like uh like the best dancer stands in
the front right and all everyone and
when you take a class I always want to
be the front one
and then in Boy Scouts I couldn't wait
till I got a leadership position like
get like patrol leader like every single
like when uh we're so different yeah
like when I was like in like a um I'm
like just leave me in my corner you're
gonna meet me occasionally I wanted to
always like finish the first
like everything I always wanted to be
either the best or the first all the
time damn I didn't I'm just like
anything that will draw attention in my
direction you know what I think it might
be I think it might stem from
um my childhood yeah yeah like I didn't
want to draw attention upon myself
because I was gonna get slammed
on by my brother and sister you know so
it's like they're ragging on each other
and I'm like I don't want to get in that
so I'm just gonna like I want nothing to
do with that
I don't know where Mike came from then
but yeah I always just wanted to be the
best or the first oh and everything and
then if I wasn't I'll find the thing
that I was really good at so like I
wanted to be the best at handball I want
to be the best at tetherball and I was
at my school and then I I played
basketball I sucked at it so I went back
to Hamilton
yeah I just always wanted to be like the
best and then
I would probably say like as soon as I
feel like I got some sort of like
high achievement then I would just back
off 100 so there's times where like I
literally get like a
the first uh test that we have in that
class and then bam just go straight to
an F after why I don't know I feel like
okay cool I got this there's no point
and then I just wouldn't like keep up
with it not knowing later on that
consistency is what produces overall
success not this giant spike in the
beginning yeah but that's how I felt for
the longest time even I joined the
military uh I was like I want to be
either guide or squad leader which are
like the two like main highest positions
when you can graduate with
like all of that
yeah no opposite I'm like give me none
of that I want none of it even if I was
the best which I never was because I
just wanted to be average I just wanted
to be in the middle I'm like I don't
want to ruffle any feathers I don't want
to cause any waves just leave me alone
yeah and then even with JK like
um
I didn't really care much for being the
first like the most subscribed YouTube
channel
um it was more about being the realist
and the edgiest you know so that was
like the thing that mattered so like I
never really tried to like get up there
in the beginning especially with like uh
Nigahiga Kev Jamba Tim whatever like I
wasn't trying to be in that race I just
wanted to feel like we were being like
the rest like the most In Living Color
the most Chappelle yeah yeah and when I
when I would watch everyone's content
I'm like oh cool ours is pretty raw and
she like that made me feel happy like
there was something I was striving for
damn maybe because it was like steaks or
something you know and then like gave it
gave things a little bit more soul
for me oh interesting
yeah that's was so interesting because
I'm just like um
I want none of that you know it's CUNY
to see kind of attack I had that a
little bit you know he just recently
competed in Jiu Jitsu yeah and so for
him like he was like wait like he's just
keeping track of colors you know he's
like wait that kid has gold I got silver
next I'm gonna come I'm gonna get gold
so he knew gold was above silver he
knows how he didn't he's just he just
knew he's just like oh you get gold or
knee like and then and then it goes gold
silver bronze like he knows what yeah
oh he won all of them oh I gotta come
back I gotta win all of them oh damn
yeah I don't know if I was like that I
mean that could just be competitive but
yeah no I mean you're competitive yeah
but I don't care because one of our
first dates we played air hockey like
seven rounds because we didn't want me
to beat you yeah but I'm doing it
because it's fun not because I need to
be number one you know what I mean like
that banter that back and forth is fun I
see but not it's not because I'm like
gonna lose sleep that I'm not number one
like I'm not the best here
would I lose sleep
I mean obviously not because it's such a
I would not I'll Loosely figuratively
like it will bother me it'll be like I'm
not like I'll feel like I didn't reach
my potential right what I didn't apply
myself 100 yeah no I don't care yeah
yeah I'm just like this was fun wasn't
it that's it and I'm like once we once I
let go of that what is it the
paddle thingy yeah I'm not thinking
about it anymore
I'm in the air hockey I don't care about
but I'm talking about like if I wasn't a
patrol leader or if I didn't get guide
or Squad yeah no I don't give a
like any of those things I'd be like man
I know I could have done it no I don't
care wow yeah I don't care I don't need
to accept so for me I'm just looking at
is like who are you oh cause you're
trying to do it for yourself because
that's the thing got it
um I don't care like obviously I joined
a team right and like let's say
everyone's like four minute mile
I'm I'm not gonna lose sleep over if I
don't get first place but if I'm
competitive and I'm like I know I can if
I try my best and that my best equals
first place
I'm gonna try my best damn and if not
I'm gonna feel very down on myself damn
no can't relate man
wow yeah I don't know if I've ever cared
to be number one in anything
is that bad I mean you're still
competitive I don't think it's bad but
it's just so interesting that like uh
uh he didn't care to be number one um I
still don't I still don't care to be
number one at all yeah
um I think I care more about
um being able to deeply connect with
people yeah now I don't care about
anything like that oh I see yeah now I
care about being well-rounded and like
kind of fulfilling all the buckets that
really mean yeah yeah exactly because
that's like a lot of the conversations
that we have you know right I tell you
like I feel like
um I can be a very good stand-up
comedian but it'd be one of those things
where it takes all of my energy to do it
yeah to tour to get myself out there but
the art form of writing I feel like I'm
pretty decent at it
um but I don't care to like get a
Netflix special and be like a top
comedian comedian you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah whereas I think if I
channeled my earlier self I would I'd be
like oh it's early yourself 20s
early 20s late teens I think I would
have been like oh I think I have a
talent in this like I'm getting this
faster than my peers I need to push
myself hard here
I see
I see because I'm like
uh I'm like then how did someone with
your personality end up like failing
everything but it's because you know
what I mean but I think it's because you
already got it and you're like I'm over
it yeah yeah but I mean that's what even
got me to probably begin with right
before Barbara Brigade I was literally
looking out like what are the state
records
and then at one point I was a top 50
deadlifter in the nation you know and I
was like oh I can get I could be
the top 165 guy that left in California
and was that because of you looked at
the records and you're like I can do
this or was it because of the oh I don't
know I thought it was because you miss
like competitive exactly same thing what
are you competing against you know uh a
competitive sport I see yeah yeah what
are you competing like what's the
purpose of training exactly so I was
just like I mean a missed competition so
how competitive am I I'm very
competitive I'm gonna compete you know
that's so interesting yeah we're so
different yeah anything that requires
um
people knowing too much about me I don't
like it and I like it when the carrot is
dangled just enough in front of me
you know what I mean
like let's say my death is 500 at the
time the state record is 520 perfect
because that pushes me so hard yeah you
know to it of course you're right there
exactly to maximize who I am so if I'm
500 the record's 510 I don't know if I
would really care
like you don't care if you apply
yourself
because obviously you have and you have
your own means to do so which is why
you're now a complete different person
that you never thought you could be so
you definitely have to apply yourself to
change I don't think I see it as like
applying myself to reach a full
potential I just see versions of myself
um or things that I want to achieve and
then I just strive for that but I don't
need to be number one and I don't obsess
about it oh I see I just I just trip
away at it you know
but I don't stop chipping away at it
you want to know what mine is that I've
never thought I could do of course yes
that you never thought you could do have
a successful relationship no okay I knew
that was gonna always be the case Okay
um
uh be an actor no
um be a musician no
am I even close no okay hold on don't
tell me
um be a good dad no
I know it's gonna be a good dad oh okay
you said I would never guess yeah I
don't I never said that I just told you
to guess oh okay
what realm is it in
it's hard to say okay then it I'm
not gonna guess it there's no way I'm
gonna guess it I never thought that I
would be able to go against my parents
what what someone like you
who your life is literally going against
your parents like every decision you've
made has been against your parents
what are you talking about yes but truly
no big no what do you mean
so you didn't finish your doctor degree
you didn't graduate with honors you
didn't marry an Asian girl you did like
you did nothing like what they wanted
you to do
and at the same time
I was still in their control how so
the way that I see it it's either
you
you go the track of your parents
or you go the true track of yourself
in the true track of yourself you make
decisions you accept full consequences
and you have you learn a hundred percent
and from there it's more of a squiggly
line
you know what I mean because you don't
know you don't know what's gonna happen
and so it's unpredictable and that's
what's beautiful about it when you go to
the track of your parents usually they
pick that track because they've seen
thousands and thousands of people go on
that track and they succeed yeah so to
them it's out of fear yeah it's out of
fear and they they think it's safe so
they want you to do it so it's already
been laid laid down 20 times
um before you yeah so for me I know that
track is go to school
get good grades go to college become a
doctor so as much as on the outside it
looks like I strayed from the track I
kept bouncing back like that was my
North Star so every single time I got
like I'd say I got kicked out of my
first school in first grade when I went
to my second school okay cool I could do
this I'm gonna try really hard try
really hard I'm gonna be a good student
got kicked out in third grade okay new
school I'm gonna try really really hard
and I'd always try to apply myself you
know Junior High in high school like it
would always bounce back because I'm
bouncing back to what they want got it
so it always felt like I it was it
always felt like
um you were failing what they wanted you
to do yeah yeah like it just felt like I
was such a bad kid for I don't know why
and I'm a bad kid in their eyes but I
gotta keep being this theme that I don't
think I am but is what they want so even
getting into UCLA is doing what they
want
you know right and uh even my job in the
Marine Corps is doing what they want
like why would you want to be a job like
stuck on the field all the time go find
like a more office based job I'm like
okay yeah so
um so and it's so Asian you know to like
do exactly what you're it's so
generational that way like where you do
exactly what your parents want and then
you become the doctor and then they
finally go okay cool you're not a
failure and then now you get married and
all that and I never ever thought either
I had the cajones or anything in the
millionaires that I was able to do that
to go like
you know what I don't want to do this I
want to try like and even even my actual
negotiation with my parents was like
give me a year give me a year to try
something the fact that I even had to
negotiate like
can I have permission to choose my life
was a huge thing you know
like isn't that crazy for a someone to
ask for permission to make their own
decisions in their own life uh how old
are you at this point like in your 20s
right yeah
that's not crazy when we're speaking
traditionally I think it's crazy it's
not crazy I think it's like a Asian
uh that's how I was raised too I
think that's like an Asian
Paradigm of some sort you know where if
you look at like white people they
generally don't do that Yeah by 18
you're an adult yeah it's like hey Mom I
want to go play soccer and whatever but
I hear that a lot with minorities though
like your 20s I really think like how
many people reach out to us where
they're like I I'm not pursuing my
passion because I'm doing what my
parents want me to do yeah exactly so
because of that
like your brother became electrician
because your dad wanted him to right so
that's why I thought I never could I
never could go against
what my parents wanted that's so
interesting to me so the reason why my
mind is blown is because you literally
so I understand that you would up
and it's kind of out of your control or
it's because of the over reaching
control
um that you would stray but then you
like you said you would just bounce
right back to what they wanted you to do
but you already have it in you
to defy it do you know what I mean I'm
not defying it but you are when you're
sneaking out of the house but that's
when you're joining a gang it looks like
I'm defying but I'm just being me
right that's Defiance no it is because
because your parents want you to be this
person so by you not being that person
and being yourself it's Defiance it's
not defined I'm being
there's a difference between your
parents wanting you to be a monkey
and then you go I'm not gonna monkey it
up and climb this tree like the way you
want me I'm saying you're Define your
parents there's a difference between
your parents wanting you to be a monkey
and climb this tree and you're going I'm
not going to Monkey it up I'm gonna jump
in the water
that's defiant what I am is my mom wants
me to be a monkey and climb this tree
but I'm like I'm a fish but that's still
defines I'm not defined because I'm a
fish I'm being me
so when I go in the water and I join the
gang or whatever and people go holy
this guy could breathe underwater I'm
like no I'm a fish like it's you're
bad for not seeing who I am
do you get what I'm saying like my my
I'm not defying I'm not choosing to
disagree I just can't it's like it's
like pushing a monkey out of a plane and
go fly fly and he's like I can't oh my
God this monkey's so defiant you're
gonna die like that's how it feels yeah
do you know what I'm saying I think so I
think I think like Defiance when you can
and you don't yes yes I do get you well
I do get you when I can't yes you you
just it's that's not me it's like
they're telling you to run but you're
like I don't have like exactly or I only
have one leg or my legs are tied
together how do I do that yeah like if I
and then that's why as the fish I would
keep crawling out of the water to try to
try to be a monkey I want to be a good
monkey and climb this tree for you so
sad but I would get up there and I don't
have the monkey arm so I fall right back
in I fall right back on the floor and
then I'm like I'm a fish
again so every single school got kicked
out of my I'm a fish I keep
breathing and I keep thriving in the
water so sad so so I know you're all
and what the hell are you doing over the
get back on this tree like all my other
friends who have other monkeys that all
climb the tree yeah yeah really good you
know yeah that is pretty so it wasn't
even until like I was like my mid-20s
when I was like you know what
can I just be a fish for a year
you know not even like put my foot down
foot down but like can I can I try being
a fish for a year and if it doesn't work
I'll go back to being a monkey
like that's that that's why I think it
was so crazy for me to ask for
permission to live my own life and I
never ever thought I could go against my
parents but it was the best decision I
ever made so that that moment for you is
when you
went against what your parents wanted to
ask for that year
yeah it took a lot of mustering like how
do I even pitch it how do I pitch it in
a way that has highest uh probability of
approval
like I had to do so much I had to get
into UCLA and graduate first before I
can even do what I wanted to do so this
whole time you knew you were gonna have
this conversation I didn't know okay so
when did it hit you that you're like I
need to have this conversation
uh when I fell in love with JK
because I didn't even know right I did
you were already doing JK
uh and then you guys took a Hiatus well
even when I was doing JK I didn't even
know that was a thing
yeah that was just for fun right that's
like taking pictures on your phone so
you don't fall in love with it yet it's
just a hobby it's just something it's
not even a hobby it's just something I
was doing that was fun I didn't even
know it was a hobby that's how new it
was oh I see you know it's like like
right now we're talking about difference
between someone that likes to take
photos on their phone and then a
photographer right I'm talking about
taking photos on my phone I don't even
know something called photography exists
um I'm just doing I'm just doing fun I'm
just recording I'm hitting the red
button start and record and stop that's
it I didn't even know I was making
content I didn't know I was doing I
didn't know I was uploading I don't know
any of that stuff yeah yeah and then so
I uh
fall in love with it
and that was the first time where like
like maybe I've jumped dived into the
ocean and I was like whoa there's a lot
of other fish here like whoa and then
I'm like
oh wait there's a difference between me
living in the ocean and being on this
tree that my mom or my dad keeps wanting
me to climb
and then I was like I kind of really
want to be in this ocean
this CUNY yeah and so it took a long
time so that so from 23
to maybe like 25 is when it took me like
two years to figure out how do I like
pitch it how do I muster up the courage
to go to my parents and be like hey I
need to do this for myself
what did you think the reaction was
going to be or what did you think that
battle was going to be that it took you
so long to or it took you mustering up
courage well I already know that 23
years they told me to be a good monkey
and climb the tree and so by you not
climbing the tree then they're like oh
you're bad because I got my ass beat for
not climbing the tree I got whipped for
not climbing the tree now you're older
they can't whip your ass anymore
what they can they're like okay cool
you're not part of our monkey Clan
um you know like I don't want to get
disowned
and they're and everybody else is a
monkey my mom's friends are all monkeys
they're all these Asians that all have
kids that go to like uc's they all like
climb the tree that they're supposed to
climb my uncle's a monkey he became a
dentist like everyone's among it's like
a monkey place you know yeah it's monkey
town for sure so I don't want to be like
well I don't want to not be a
monkey
you know I'm a
like everyone I know is a monkey
like I guess I have to be a monkey no
matter what yeah and it's just another
mindset you didn't even know yeah so I
know that
if I even explored this fish thing I
created a giant gap between me and all
the other monkeys who are all my family
and friends that's so interesting to me
because um and maybe because we've been
together for so long and now we've grown
up as fishes in this ocean
um that maybe I did forget what it was
like in the beginning for us and for me
and like
I think early on I knew that but I guess
I wasn't my ass wasn't beat and it
wasn't instilled and drilled in me the
way it was for you but for me I didn't
know
other things existed because I hadn't
seen that whatever I saw before me
the path that I was supposed to follow
was already followed by my mom my dad my
older sister and my brother so that's
the only path I know but I just knew
that path wasn't for me
I knew that there's all this path and it
felt like a a path full of friction yeah
I didn't know there's any other avenues
at all
even JK I didn't know that was in an
Avenue
until there we started getting AdSense
and then there was a Yahoo report that
came out that needed hero captured
multiple guys were making six figures
off their YouTube when I was like oh
this can be a job
that was my first thing and I and I
remember exactly in my apartment when I
saw that article come out on Yahoo and
me and Joe talked about it because it
was such a crazy moment that was like
someone like my whole life I'm a fish I
don't know I'm a fish I just know I'm a
very bad monkey then this was the first
time a zoologist comes out and goes hey
did you know you're a fish and I'm like
what
like that yeah
um no the point I was making was
um so I knew that this path I didn't
know any of the other ones existed I
knew this path wasn't my path
but I just needed to follow it because
it was safe so that but I was always
kind of
um I kept my eyes and ears open I guess
to other things that would align to the
thing I didn't know existed but I wanted
right so I think that's why when JK
rolled around for me it was a no-brainer
you know like nothing was promised
didn't know how far I was going to get
in it but it was way more down like up
my alley than what I was currently doing
but I also don't think your parents have
it instilled in exactly that's what I
was saying of course that's what I was
saying um they didn't instill it in me
but there was definitely gonna be some
disowning all this other I think
the only thing that would be equivalent
is you know how your parents never
wanted any of the kids to study out of
state yeah it would have been if you
started your freshman year of college on
the East Coast that'd be the same
equivalent
so imagine then your Junior and Senior
year of high school mustering up the
courage to let them know you've got
accepted and you already have your
flight booked and you're going to study
on the other side of America yeah I
guess it just doesn't apply because
um if I wasn't a and so sheltered
I didn't do that because I was scared
exactly I'm scared too uh not scared
about them yeah what they're gonna think
about me I didn't I was over it like
that didn't stop me from doing anything
um I was just scared for my safety
because I didn't know I had never left
my front yard
um but let's say I had a little bit more
freedom oh dude for sure you know I'll
deal with the consequences later I'm out
you know that's it when I the
opportunity for me to move out which is
against what like I was going to be
disowned my mom was telling me like your
dad's gonna yell at you he's never gonna
like he's gonna kick you up maybe right
away like you don't want to have this
conversation that I'm like I just don't
have this conversation
you know so I I can't really relate to
what you're saying that's why it blows
my mind because you're such a
um you're such a like I just see you as
such as like an alpha person and a
person that just is so focused and
dedicated and driven and and and just
so about what what he wants that like to
hear that you had this like
fear of what your parents were gonna
think
and how you couldn't muster like you
needed courage to speak to them to get
it done that I'm like
what it just blows my mind that's
probably my biggest achievement to this
date is getting my life back
your life was because you gotta imagine
like like starting day one
TV is taped
you know I was I've been to monk
camp like none of my I didn't have time
weekends I was doing homework or doing
chores like I couldn't really hang out
that much like my I was on lockdown
lockdown yeah yours is really bad I
never listen to the radio so I was
locked down but locked down with freedom
inside my house yeah you could watch TV
I could eat whatever I want to watch TV
talk on the phone like I had freedom
anything with artificial flavors so no
Capri Suns none of that I had all that
can't watch TV I had cable yeah I can't
even listen to the radio I listen to I
had my own radio music for the first
time when I was in fifth grade yeah I
bought a Boombox over
um I had my own radio and my own room
yeah I couldn't choose my clothes I
could I choose my haircut you know like
I mean all that stuff yeah yours is
really bad and so like I never I never
had my life you know that's true and
that's like in third grade like I wanted
to commit suicide I was like what the
I don't even like my life yeah I
never had my life I never made any
choices
damn that is a huge achievement yeah I
mean how does one even think that they
can achieve that for sure like
you never saw anything else yeah so I
was just like okay I constantly have to
live this other track that someone told
me to to go on what was the thing where
you were like nah it has to happen like
it had like I have to just give it my
all because you were under so much
control that like
yeah how are you is it just a will no it
was more so being real with myself
like um
when
and it was it wasn't like one big
pivotal moment but it was a gradual
discovery of myself
so like when I started to realize first
um in college I'm like I loved shooting
skits and stuff with Joe and our
director Danny at the time and I
couldn't wait to do that and I don't
know how many all-nighters we pulled to
shoot skits because we were we would
shoot them get so excited we'd want to
edit immediately so we'd edit until the
morning I don't know how many times
they've done that right I compare that
with pulling all-nighters to study it's
like day or night difference
interesting not even like an interesting
like I can articulate it but it just
feels like something feels very warm and
welcoming and the other one was like
like pulling teeth
then I graduate
and I'm like damn what am I supposed to
do well I got to study for MCAT and all
that stuff anyways but I was still doing
skits and stuff on the side and um just
like almost every step I took in this
direction and this direction this one
just felt more and more honest
to the point where uh I was like wait
this is I think
really me and it feels
um like I'm living the correct life and
it feels like this is a lie
so I think I couldn't lie to myself
anymore
that's good you know and I felt like I
had to go
hey monkeys you know what like I'm I'm
not a monkey I don't think I'm a monkey
yeah yeah I remember when you and I were
friends and you were going you were in
this phase and like remember we would
talk on AIM and as homies
um you would talk about how one of your
dreams was to like like you really
wanted to be a singer and a lot of
things like were just pointing like you
would take singing lessons and like you
were doing all of your hobbies were
centered more around entertainment than
they were in any type of medical field
yeah like things that are technically
non-productive yeah I was at UCLA and
then I was just taking singing lessons
to add to nothing but I just thought it
was dope it was fun because I never I've
never been properly trained I'm like
that's what this would be cool yeah yeah
I remember having conversations with you
and feeling bad for you
um because I'm like damn like this guy
is doing something he's like he's trying
to appease his parents like image of him
yeah like I remember feeling it from you
yeah living up to an image living up to
a monkey image and I'm not yeah and I
mean I'm not your girlfriend nor like
were we tight like that where I'd be
like you don't want it to be not ever
um but it wasn't like I didn't feel like
it was my place to have and I wasn't
mature enough to like even articulate or
even understand any of this stuff but I
just knew that I was just like oh man
his his life seems like a bummer like
when you would just do the medical stuff
because I'm like that's not him at all
yeah yeah that's crazy okay so then uh
over
um I mean you kind of always just felt
dislike I don't belong with monkeys I'm
definitely if other something else
um you see that
oh uh uh you're still trying to study
but you're doing the fun stuff on the
side
and then at what point oh is it the
article you said
the article that started telling you who
the top that was like the first uh
sign of feasibility
because you're like you can make a
living off of this you know in the Asian
track it's after college you got to make
money or you go more school
so I was like oh there is money here so
I can have a job so I don't have to go
more school if I can pursue it enough
yeah so that was like the first thing
that was like okay maybe I could try it
uh but at this point you did you weren't
even thinking about talking to them yet
um I did and I knew the Doomsday was
coming up because I was going to
graduate so when I graduate what do I do
like that there has to be an explanation
why I'm not in medical school
or taking more classes yeah what
happened there um I don't remember that
part because I I was with you
when you graduated
but I don't know like my timeline is a
little bit up I don't know if you
already
doing
no I would think I was still probably
working at the bank
and you weren't full-time jk just yet no
you took the summer off
uh that summer or no no so I thought I
graduated remember we walked in all that
and then I found out I was missing a
class like before I could pick up my
diploma yeah so I spent that summer
getting
um taking that one last random like GE
is history class and then was that
around the time that you were like oh no
I need to do JK full-time or not yet
that's the time I wanted to I but it
wasn't a business business so remember I
sold my car out of a blue truck so I
sold it to buy the Tahoe so I had 10 G's
and remember I was waking up at like 4
a.m every morning to stop to learn
stocks yeah like I was like I I had to
that's how much I wanted to be this fish
I'm like my fish isn't affording my
lifestyle so what can I do on the side
to make money so I could explore being
this fish
you know and is there enough things I
could pull together to make it work so
that I can fish full time yeah okay so
you did that yeah um but you had to
explain your parents were for sure
curious as to why you're selling this
truck so I'm sure you had to have had a
conversation there somewhere yeah I just
told them that's what I want to do I
want to sell the truck and uh I want to
use this money and start to learn about
stocks and I guess they were completely
cool with it they're like well that's
fine you know we understand stocks so
we're for it and they're like well
you're an adult now so you can uh we we
bought you this truck so you can do
whatever you want with it
yeah not knowing that you weren't
going to go back to med school
um they thought you were still going to
do that yeah yeah I see yeah they still
thought I was going to go to med school
and stuff and then um who did you break
it to First
uh
um
my mom I think oh yeah cause I was
closer with my mom at that time I see so
I told her and then I I said I was this
is
I want to try it and then it was it's
definitely not like a one conversation
it was probably like multiple
conversations yeah I'm sure and then
different Renditions of the same
conversation yeah and I'm sure they had
questions yeah and it took probably like
a month you know and then both of them
both of my parents thought I was stupid
yeah would you go halfway yeah of course
you're halfway there why would you why
would you give up this why'd you go to
such a good school and all that yeah
yeah because I went to a good school
because you wanted me to go to good
school
you know so I had to do like that whole
like explain to them like how my whole
life I yeah yeah didn't even haven't
done what I wanted yet just let you know
and I have to explain all of that to
finally um them go find just one year
then
that's cool yeah yeah that's fair a year
if tiger were to ask me for but
it's crazy that I have to ask to live my
life for a year that's the crazy it's
not crazy
um and I don't see it as crazy
uh because they know that the burden's
gonna fall back on them well for me I'm
like no for taika he could live whatever
do whatever he wants that's his life
yeah it is okay so I would agree if it
doesn't involve me yeah if if you leave
my house I don't have to worry about you
financially or you coming back and now
like uh what's the word like now
disrupting whatever new life I want
that's exactly
that's exactly it but that's not true
because weren't your parents like still
giving you money no I I already told
them like I told them what my plan like
you know how I am I'm a very calculated
person yeah so I told my mom step number
one I go to med school
step number two I become a doctor or
some sort of healthcare professional in
the military I'm already prior military
they're gonna highly value who I am step
number three I'm gonna be a police
officer step number four I'll go back
and I'll be an officer in the Marine
Corps because I already have a uh a
bachelor's and I was a former Marine and
they'll take me and then so you don't
have to worry so I have four things
planned
you know what I mean why do you do four
like that that's so hard why don't you
just do like that
because I was counting this way
oh you started with your thumb yeah I'm
like you ended so awkwardly
I would be like one two three four
one three four man you make your life so
difficult so I had four things planned
plan a plan B plan C Plan D
you know plan e let me do try JK try
YouTube
so that's how I had I was like the first
four plans
doesn't require you I'm gonna have a
full-time job you don't have to worry
about me at all
and then even then it was still
reluctancy I'm like what the how
many more backup plans do you need from
me
you know because I'm not gonna fall on
your shoulders I'm never gonna be your
burden I'm a military I'm a prior
military and I have a bachelor's from
UCLA I'm like I'm a catch
I could apply the Deloitte or
Goldman Sachs or anybody right
now I'll start from the bottom up and
I'll be six figures in like
three years no matter what I do yeah
yeah I'm a kid they missed that
part right so I'm like if I'm a
catch and I work hard
I'm like
what's the problem right right and then
but in Asians it doesn't matter
logic ration doesn't matter yeah it
didn't it's just like all they hear is
oh you don't want to be a monkey
Monkey Town you know I don't think they
hear that I think they hear um like no
but what if it doesn't work out like
then he's gonna suffer but I got four
plans Playa I know but
they're just they're scared people yeah
yeah I see
damn
so then you tell her and it was a lot of
back and forth and then after a month
they were like it's cool
does month try it and then now the year
of me trying it is literally every
single day so are you done yet are you
gonna go back every day literally every
day every day even even
um when you know the first big
eye-opening moment is remember when
Jacob got the office I couldn't wait to
bring my parents there because it was
like oh it's Now official we got an
office they can see it with their own
eyes we got employees that are like holy
this is a company and even till
then how long do you think it's Gonna
Last though
like you know
it's like it's constantly like and then
they'll see us shooting or do whatever
like see if you're a dentist you have to
work to worry about that or if a
chiropractor you have to worry about
that just constantly just throwing those
things back in my face yeah like all I
felt like a bunch of backhanded
compliments so even after I found some
sort of traction and going against my
parents it was still constantly like but
are you sure you read the made the right
move yeah so at what point were you like
oh I did that
um at what point
because it eventually backed off I think
when uh we started paying my mom
allowance so then it just sounds like it
was your mom that was a big issue
because you didn't pay your dad
um well it's because I I didn't think I
owed my dad as much
yeah so it sounds like it's coming from
your mom more than my mom and my dad um
but so where did your dad stop well the
reason why I felt like I owed my mom is
because uh for that first year for for
JK to take off the reason why it took
off is because my mom didn't charge us
for rent right so we got to run JK out
of a rent-free place we got to live
their rent free so that was a huge help
right even though it was only what like
I don't know a thousand bucks a month or
something yeah that's huge when
you have zero well and she was giving us
money too remember
was she oh but it was it's a huge thing
to like she would give me money
yeah yeah
I don't remember that yeah she would
well anyways to not charge rent to run
JK out of there I was like oh this
is awesome so the minute that we
could I was like I felt like I need to
repay her back so yeah uh but being able
to give her allowance now was like oh
the turns have tabled you know the
turns have tabled indeed yeah okay and
then this was how many years after that
like maybe two or three no way more yeah
way more so damn for all of those years
they were on here I was still getting it
in the ear every day
in the ear every day yeah
because the JK office was at the uh
front house remember then it went to the
middle house and then we finally got the
office so we don't need an office
anymore so we moved into the back house
when we moved into the back house I
would still kind of get it and then it
wasn't until
um
we moved to probably moved to Alhambra
where we're like okay we support
ourselves and they support you
and we have a gym and we have JK
for them to like finally like
chilled out on it a little bit you know
damn yeah that's so that's what I don't
know that's like
like I don't know seven years after I
graduate graduated I was still getting
an earful the whole time and they're
like you're three years away from being
a full doctor you stupid
it's not me I'm not monkey
damn
so that's that to me is like that's
something I never thought I could break
away from
and after the seven years it was never
brought up again right because you were
just you're driving your Porsche
and you have this other car and you had
your big ass houses and
and now you're like bowling yeah
now it's not it's fine now I make all
the decisions and I schooled them why I
make the decisions and they go okay yes
I understand how does that feel
awesome like hey that's why I'ma
move to Vegas oh good son
that's good
does it ever blow your mind where I'm
like where you're just like it's
little Bart
if I told little Bart that this is what
he's gonna turn out he wouldn't believe
me like that type of or you're like
nah little Bart kind of always knew no I
think it would be mind-blowing
yeah I think it's the same thing as like
when you first time you like outgrow
your parents you're like what like that
the first time I realized that my my
bandwidth and like Pro CPU my processing
power is bigger than my parents I was
like oh I'm like from this point on
I wear the big boy I tell you
what's gonna happen and then you
nod your head
yeah
so like you know like I didn't have to
get my parents approval
um when we moved to Vegas or why I have
to do anything you know whereas my uncle
who still lives in an Asian track who's
was still asking for approval for every
single thing that he's doing like hey
can I take my family I'm gonna take my
family on a vacation to Tori Yosemite
what do you think why would you want to
spend all that kind of money you know
that's what my grandma say
even him at 50 60 is under that
Asian thumb like the Asian thumb was
strong
it's hard to like be able to talk to
your parents like that
people are in their 60s and 70s still
like under that Asian thumb I mean it
has his pros and his cons for sure but
damn but you did it yeah you did
it and it's really dope
that we've been able to like really
stare at
the ugliness and be like okay this
is not working we gotta change it and
have the
the working capacity to just one
foot in front of the other lay one break
down and then the other brick and then
the other break it's a lot of hard work
yeah
just trying to be honest to who I am
this CUNY you're a fish yeah you should
get a fish tattoo
give me what is CUNY
yeah no we've we've uh We've developed a
lot it's pretty rad to kind of like look
back at it and be like oh it's kind
of like when you um God Mia farts so
much I can just going on your
dad's side it's thick it's like this
thick spicy fart it's so nasty uh but
it's kind of like you know when you take
your first picture day one of your diet
and then like three months in you're
like because like you see yourself every
day and you don't really think of it
much you're like man this progress is so
slow but then when you do a side-by-side
comparison you're like oh
I've come a long way yeah it's pretty
cool to see it now to be like damn we've
come a long way yeah it came from my TVs
getting taped up to not having a TV
room every single room and I
guess what I can pull it off and tilt it
I got the tilt you even have one
on your bone yeah that's how
many TVs yeah yeah I listen to music
whenever I want now Mom yeah Mom
anytime I want I get the haircuts that I
want boom I get to wear whatever I want
too yeah exactly let's go I get a lead
whoever I want to eat to eat meat
yeah that one's rough all right well on
that note
that was a good question thank you for
asking that
um is there anything you want to discuss
add shout out always shout outs the
barbell brigades always got new drops
every single month this year we got a
lot of Fire coming your way so make sure
you check that out uh apparel we got
some brand new supplements that we're
working on that is delicious too so go
to bottlebrigade.com and check it all
out see you guys next time bye